[Music]
hello and welcome to atp report i'm your
host barry nussbaum
remember i ask everybody every week to
take out your cell phone and text the
message truth t-r-u-t-h in the message
box and send us the number 88202
you'll be signed up to get this episode
and all of our content from american
truth project
in the palm of your hand on your cell
phone absolutely for free our guest
today is friend of atp our correspondent
to all
the knowledge about islam we have the
world famous robert spencer with us he's
a published author of over 20 books he's
the founder and editor of jihad watch he
is the american scholar on islam welcome
back robert always good to talk to you
barry thank you
thanks for coming on today so let's
start off with this guy that you wrote
about uh al khalidi 74 he died in jordan
last month from covid kovid
this is a guy that over the years has
made some
outlandish statements about jews and
israelis he's called them pigs and
devils he's cited numerous quranic
verses
claiming jews are leading the western
crusaders in their war against islamic
nation
he makes all the quotes about how jews
are the pigs the devils in the land of
palestine
he talks about the lions of al-qasam
brigades that are killing the jews in
israel
and uh eventually we will rid the world
of jews now a guy this horrible
why
how is he a famous guy to be revered in
the world of islam when he passes away
well we have to remember barry that
everything he said that you just listed
there is all based on islamic teaching
the idea of uh jews as pigs comes from
the quran chapter 2 verses 63 to 65
chapters 15 chapter 5 verses 59 and 60
and chapter 7 verse 166 allah transforms
the disobedient jews into apes and pigs
and it's a staple of jihadi rhetoric to
this day that the israelis are the
children of apes and pigs or the
brothers of apes and pigs and
consequently
to be held in utter contempt and hatred
the jews are the worst enemies of the
muslims according to chapter 5 verse 82
of the quran and there are numerous
other anti-semitic verses throughout the
quran that make it clear that the jews
are constantly scheming against the
muslims or the muslims enemies and so on
so al khalidi is really just expressing
mainstream islamic thought and that's
why he was so revered and why even now
the head of american muslims for
palestine which is ostensibly a
respectful organization is eulogizing
him in the most fulsome terms as if he
were someone to be respected because
this kind of thought
is mainstream all over
let me let me stop you right there
here's the part that really bothers me
you quote everything this man said and
it is horrible
and then
you quote the praise heaped on top of
him which makes the horribleness even
worse
why is it robber
that nobody but you
happens to point this out
well very few people in the west have
read the quran or think that it's
relevant to this issue at all
as a matter of fact the whole enterprise
of the
israeli-palestinian peace process
so-called is based on ignoring quranic
and islamic imperatives regarding the
muslims and the jews
if the american foreign policy experts
so-called
would
uh
study the koran and study islam
they would know a whole lot more about
the israeli-palestinian conflicts than
they do today because every last
palestinian leader from mahmoud abbas to
khalid michal to isma haniyeh to every
last one of them
they always situate the conflict in
terms of islam and yet that's completely
off the radar as far as the us state
department is concerned they don't have
any interest in it whatsoever and they
think it's just rhetorical window
dressing when actually it's the key to
understanding the palestinian arab
perspective on the whole conflict
well said and i wish more people would
read jihad watch
by you so they would understand this so
let's talk history a little bit i i was
very intrigued um by the super bowl
not what was on the field but what
happened in the stands robert you had 70
plus thousand people there
the tickets were very hard to get they
were very expensive and it was in los
angeles so it was a who's who of
celebrity dumb in the stands
all of them
maskless
including the governor
all the mayors and most of the
politicians of the state of california
however
in spite of the fact that there are
massive mandates for masks in california
at the super bowl you didn't see any
and yet when the kids went back to
school the next day they had to wear
masks under all kinds of threats so the
celebrities and i've got a list like
this long of the who's who of hollywood
and music both um
famous and people i haven't heard of
that seem to be famous why is it
that there are masks for thee but not
for me
and that's okay well unfortunately barry
this is a hallmark of authoritarian
regimes throughout history that the
elites are exempt from the rules that
they make for the common people uh as a
matter of fact you go back to the
foundation of anglo-american law the
magna carta in the year 1215 the idea
was to change
the
idea that there would be one rule for
one set of rules for the nobility and
another set of rules for the common
people and to establish the uh the
principle of one law for all people and
that's been the hallmark of free
societies ever since until now but of
course now what we have are free
societies that are becoming less free
and as a result they are we are seeing
once again
the idea
recurring of elites not feeling
themselves bound by what they force upon
us
and so uh unfortunately this is a sign
of the incipient authoritarianism that
the left is imposing upon us everywhere
i learned something really interesting
from none other than you
uh robert spencer which was
in the middle ages
when
islam was being founded by muhammad
the idea of women only wearing masks was
instituted it was a fascinating series
of articles i read by you can you give
us a little brief history of where this
idea came from and why the masks only
for women and not for men
sure in the first place muhammad
according to islamic tradition ordered
that his wives be veiled
so that nobody would be able to see them
and lust after them because that would
be an insult to him
as the husband of these various women he
had
between 11 and 13 wives depending on how
some of them are counted but in any case
they all had to be covered up
so that only muhammad would be able to
see them at all and this was a sign of
also the respect that the believers were
supposed to have for the household of
muhammad then later on the veiling order
was extended to all muslim women and
there are hadiths reports of muhammad's
words and deeds that have him saying
that women should cover everything but
the face in the hands which you see
often in islamic societies and then
sometimes you even see them covering
their faces that's an extension of the
same principle because if the whole
thing is designed to prevent men from
being tempted if men are still tempted
by a face then you cover the face
and and
i remember something about it it seems
to
control them in a way um
you know
as everyone knows from face masks it's
hard to get enough error uh you feel
stifled um it's hard to communicate
you're sort of in a portable cage so to
speak is there a control mechanism
involved in this as well oh there's no
doubt about it whatsoever women are
decidedly subordinate in islam most
notoriously in chapter 4 34 there is the
mandate to beat women it says from whom
you fear disobedience they don't even
have to be disobedient you just have to
be afraid they might be someday uh
there's no beating of disobedient men
and
uh women
are also essentially reduced to the
status of commodities by the very idea
of polygamy where you have one man but
not an equal relationship as marriage in
the west is envisioned but as
commodities up to four and then you can
also have the sex slaves this is all
mandated in the quran so
the uh covering is kind of a sign of
that that this woman is the possession
of this one individual and nobody else
has even visual exits
honestly the only word that comes to
mind is
it's disgusting
um i
i've never understood
how americans um either muslim americans
or non-muslim americans who are
sympathetic will say oh no it's a sign
of freedom it's a sign of independence
it's a sign
that they are powerful
women with certain rights
that are protected by their covering it
seems to me the words don't match the
facts do you agree oh yeah that's just
pr that's just designed to fool
complacent westerners into thinking that
there's something wrong with speaking
out against this uh the fact is you know
it's so crazy barry there's there's such
insanity in the world today and one
example of it is world hijab day
which is i believe february 2nd every
year now all these western feminists put
on the hijab to show their solidarity
with muslim women who were supposedly
oppressed by non-muslims who disliked
their wearing hijab
actually i don't know of any case i'm
sure that somewhere that
some muslim woman has actually been
harassed by some non-muslim law
that that's unacceptable wherever it may
have happened but the fact is i know
plenty of cases where muslim women have
claimed to have been harassed by some
non-muslim lao and then turned out to
have been lying
meanwhile
all over the islamic world and also in
the west in texas in mississauga ontario
and elsewhere we have seen
muslim women who don't wear hijab being
brutalized or even killed by their own
family members for not wearing it so if
the western feminists really had a clue
and really cared about women's rights
they would be having no hijab day which
is also been started up by a few
ex-muslim women very courageously
but not this world hijab day that
prevails now yeah it seems to me to be a
celebration of um
sort of a slavery uh
in in a sense and the idea that western
uh people with liberal values would
support that is is beyond disgusting
speaking of just
outside the bounds of human decency uh
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
has just now declared emergency powers
to move against the freedom convoy
the canadian government says they're
going to freeze the asset of every
trucker
participating in the protest they're
going to cancel their insurance policies
they're going to seize their bank
accounts they're going to grab their
trucks i mean
it sounds almost like fascism
what's your take on
justin trudeau as the leader of canada
especially as of today i think five or
six of the provinces in canada have said
no more mass mandates
but not the federal government that's
right
uh justin trudeau is a fascist uh
fascism is quintessentially the uh not
the
control of all the means of production
as in communism uh where the state
becomes essentially the the owner of
everything but rather the control of all
the means of production by means of
forcing the various means of production
to tow the government line and uh
trudeau by invoking this and trampling
upon the civil liberties of these
protesters is showing himself
to have been telling the truth when he
was asked years ago in 2013
what his uh the country he most admired
was and he said china because their
authoritarian government allows them to
get things done directly they have to
worry about parliaments and give and
take and debate and compromise and now
we see that's the kind of government he
does want and that he's bringing to
canada and what's really scandalous is
that joe biden has not denounced him and
that he hasn't fallen from a
no-confidence vote uh it's so it's an
astonishing
world historical development the
destruction of freedom in canada
you know it really you you raise a
really interesting point here uh so many
times in history these tyrants
don't rise from nowhere and surprise
everyone with their agenda they let you
know ahead of time what they believe in
and what they plan to do
lenin did it
mao did it hitler did it they write
books about it they make speeches and if
you just listen they'll tell you what
their agenda's going to be justin
trudeau did it
years ago and now his fondest dreams of
total control over canada are being at
least implemented with the attempt to be
communist china and i guess we'll see
whether or not he's successful in the
next coming days because
as i said the provinces are saying no
while trudeau from the federal level is
saying yes there will be
some sort of conflict at some point i'm
rooting for the provinces
instead of the federal government in
canada and i assume you are too
absolutely
so robert tell people where they can
find out about you and follow you on
social media yeah i'm at ghodwatch.org
updated every day with news and
commentary about jihad activity in the
united states and around the world and
at g hot watch rs on twitter there is
also a g hot watch facebook page i bet
you won't be able to find it because it
is so shadow banned but it does exist
i find it i work to find you because i
think you're worth the effort and i
would urge all of our viewers out in atp
land follow robert spencer you will
learn some things from him that you
won't find anywhere else and robert's a
scholar he gives you the source of what
he's teaching you so you
can understand it and teach others
thanks for coming on today with atp i
sure appreciate your viewership today i
want to remind you please sign up for
our text message alert system simply
text the word truth and send it to the
number 88202 you'll be signed up
instantly and you'll get all of robert
spencer
on atp report absolutely for free again
thanks for coming on with us today
i'm barry nussbaum